lundi que cette femme est sortie de
l'anonymat elle enchaîne les conneries
avec une régularité qu'il faut lui
reconnaître
évidemment elle vient me chercher sur
mon terrain et défend le foot payant
quand je préconise le foot de ligue 1
gratuit à la tv alors accusé - espèce de
tourtes le foot gratuit à la télé à part
être le fruit d'un serment très malade
ou très fait pour le buzz à deux balles
je ne vois pas alors arrive gentil ella
elle l'a mal pris forcément évidemment
donc bah oui à tout retour à train
d'autres derrière elle arrive de
retraite de tous voilà et donc on a
envoyé gilles verdez puisque gilles
verdez balai sur le bateau qui radient
sont ils sont en train de tourner en ce
moment puisqu'elle est chroniqueuse chez
thierry ardisson et il va lui amener une
tourte et un bouquet de fleurs là dans
la foi qu'il a mené des pizzas c'est à
joey starr s'est plutôt mal terminé
sachez que gilles verdez sera prêt dans
une minute les chéris mais il est parti
depuis longtemps il est parti
enregistrer lille à la plaine saint paul
il ya une heure il ya une heure de
trajet gilles verdez il va rentrer
regarder alors gilbert desk et sur le
plateau qui varient n'est ce pas ce
tiramisu apparemment le cadreur et perdu
voilà le cadre voilà merci gilles verdez
qui est là il va arriver sur le plateau
il amène une tourte arts à quelques
années la collection la collection à
l'espace messieurs
alors j'essaie autre est rentré ses
livreurs ces livreurs à kehl bonjour
pierre ménès en pratique dire terminer
sa famille et au nom tout les files de
plus qu'à mon poste en tant que libraire
attitré je vous offre une magnifique
tour tu es un magnifique bouquet de
fleurs en toute amitié
la tonne c'est bon 1 oui les délicieuses
ai fait moi-même
sauf que quand elle est remplie de
grossièreté de vulgarité ok je viens
avec ce bouquet pour faire la paix ce
grand brassage et aime bien vous parce
que vous vous êtes jambes mais on s'aime
touche mais les entre là il faut arrêter
avec la con et vous pourrez y entendre
beaucoup les gens pendant alors pourquoi
maintenant
ouais ça va arriver à calais cécile
il faut qu'on
j'aime ça va marcher j'en ai dû à la
fatigue et du reste alors à cet âge il a
l'air brassé alors match et qu'eric est
en train de tourner pour dimension des
mesures ni gens dans ces tueries
[Applaudissements]
il a fait
salle
[Applaudissements]
c'est lors de laquelle la caisse amadieu
au curé maison
voulait nous parler ça va à l allure
qu'il a pu dire oui à la dirigeante
était vulgaire des socialistes il arrive
le pauvre que j'étais son qui n'a rien
d'acquis passive
le pauvre gars et je fais deux heures et
demie avec un bouquet de fleurs
[Applaudissements]